so let's start with optimism I just want
to sort of get your intuitions going
about what a sort of common sense notion
of optimism might be optimism that
something is going to occur looks to me
anyway likes something like this it's a
desire that that thing occur you desire
nice weather tomorrow and you think it's
probable you think the odds are better
than 5050 that it's going to rain that
it's going to be sunny tomorrow so it's
something you want and it's something
you think is probable you might even
think it's certain so you're pretty sure
that 2+2 is going to continue to equal
for tomorrow you can say I'm optimistic
that 2+2 will continue to equal 4 so
that looks like a way of thinking about
optimism that's kind of at least a
sketch I think of our common sense
notion the counterpart notion I think in
hope with respect to hope is this desire
for the thing so you still think it's
good and desirable but instead of
believing that it's probable or
estimating it as probable or certain do
you think that it's merely possible
so this gets us away from the classical
conflation of the two notions you can
hope for something that you don't think
is at all probable I might hope that I'm
going to I don't know upload my mind
onto a computer after the singularity
and live forever but I don't feel
optimistic that that's going to be the
case right so there's a difference
between these concepts hope and optimism
and of course there's a difference with
respect to wish I might wish that the
Warriors had won the finals
that sounds coherent but if I now say I
know the Warriors lost but I really hope
that they want you would think that was
somehow I just didn't get the concept
right so wish is different from hope as
well that can't be the whole story about
hope though so there's this interesting
point that even someone who despairs the
opposite of hope might desire the thing
and believe that it's possible so what
else do we have to add to get genuine
hope I like to take this case from this
movie people in the literature have
brought this up before I did but I like
the case the Shawshank Redemption some
of you will have seen it it's a Stephen
King story turned into a
movie we've got two characters both of
them have a life sentence both of them
really want to get out both of them
think it's possible but one of them
succumbs to fear and despair and the
other is sort of motivated by hope to
start digging behind the bed every night
until he finally gets out through the
sewers and ultimately feels a lot better
than he did when he was inside so what's
the difference it looks like and this is
actually a quotation from the from the
movie it looks like read the guy who
despairs has the same estimation of the
possibility of probability of what's of
what they both want but sort of
articulates it differently so read says
I grant you that it's possible so I
grant you that it's possible but it's so
unlikely the odds are so long it's gonna
be so hard
Andy says I grant you that the odds are
so long but it's possible focuses on the
possibility so what I want to suggest is
that we call this focus on the positive
possibility that hope involves as
opposed to despair actually focusing
attending to the fact that something is
possible letting that motivate a certain
kind of maybe effort to look for
pathways or projects start digging
behind the bed getting yourself involved
thinking about that positive possibility
and holding it before yourself in a way
that might motivate action positive
emotion but it's not irrational it's not
just producing optimism in yourself you
still acknowledge the fact that this is
an extremely unlikely outcome and yet
you remain hopeful
[Music]